[Musique]
l'engouement pour la noisette existe
depuis belle lurette
plusieurs ont de beaux souvenirs
d'enfance reliés à ce petit fruit la
noisette quand elle est dans l'art
berçant massa c'est à dire qu'il ya une
enveloppe verts qui ressemble à une
feuille de chaque côté de la noisy qu'on
appelle un beau look puis à l'intérieur
se trouve la noisy c'est pas une cote
très épaisse relativement facile à
casser
puis ensuite à l'intérieur yonne une
belle noiseuse pour alain perreault se
lancer dans la production de noisettes
c'est aussi cultiver sa patience mais
j'ai un noisetier ci qui pendant huit
ans faisait que des feuilles faisait pas
de fruits j'étais découragé je voulais
le couper
puis la première ni qu'a produit a
produit 8 kg pour moi c'est intéressant
d'un point de vue ses économies d'un
point de vue d'une nouvelle culture et
d'un point de vue aussi gustatif
gastronomique ce la noisette sauvage
c'est la longue bec mais pour le jardin
des noix la diversité est garante de
l'avenir la production naturelle va pas
se concentrer sur la production de
noisettes ans avec jeanne pense pas
n'empêche qu'il ya des gens qui ont
intérêt pour en planter par souci de
préserver la biodiversité patrimoine
mais ça va aller plutôt vers des
variétés de noisetier hybride une
noisette un peu plus grosses avec des
productivité plus élevée aussi moins
sensibles à certains insectes dans
quelques années je pense que on aura la
possibilité d'offrir des bonnes quand
c'est des gens pour partir avec de
quelques kilos sûrement la demande peut
venir aussi des restaurateurs qui
veulent de plus en plus les cuisines et
john winter grâce aux étangs des
chiffres qui s'est donné comme mission
de cuisine et que des produits locaux
chaque fois que tout ça c'est des choses
qui sont intéressants parce que ces
bébés
certes nous avons apporté ou chef les
fruits de notre récolte des noisettes
cultiver pour commencer je perds maman
très bon
jean lormant c'est quand même c'est plus
humide
c'est ce que ça veut dire c'est moins
craquant que la noisette qu'on peut
goûter dans une bâtisse qui il y as
commandant côté amertume qui reste
regarde ton n'osaient pas rentrer et il
ya là c'est ça vous tente tout ce que
vous inspire pas man was it sauvage il
est très différent c'est pâques raconte
ce cas mais c'est juste des fibres
ouailles aussi brûlé beaucoup moins
goûteux beaucoup moins parfumé celle là
pas étonnant puisque ces noisettes
sauvages ne devrait pas être dégusté
après la cueillette
elles ont besoin de plusieurs mois de
séchage avant d'être consommés comme le
goût qui finissent moi j'avais décrit
comme un goût de forêt c'est comme dans
il a ça vous inspire quoi aujourd'hui
avec ses noisettes
c'est la saison des chanterelles allons
parler des chanterelles avec les
haricots soit en pleurer de fer a mano
puis après ça on va justement pays
montant de noisettes compte par dessus
c'est très beau et très odorant ça sent
le bois
oui c'est ce parcours n'est pas qu'un
culture à quelque chose
le savary comme henning bien distillerie
vous avez été généreux quand même la sas
a beau être pas beaucoup on va lutter
voir ça goûte la noisette
c'est vraiment très très bon le mélange
avec les champignons accès se marie bien
son côté mais c'est comme encore plus
intense le fait qu'on m'a dit c'est de
savoir alors ensemble c'est vraiment
très très bon ton pour une touche plus
sucré john praline les noisettes avec du
sirop d'érable et les dépôts simplement
sur une crème glacée maison mais c'est
merveilleux parce que on goûte encore
très très bien la noisette
c'est encore très franc comme goût
malgré qu'ils ont été près l'une est
dans du sirop d'érable de sang les
oiseaux qui sont comme paris avec des
choses qui sont déjà très goûteux comme
des choses j'avais des choses chaque
année mais les noisettes c'est quand
même une noix qui très goûteuse ans en
taxes et impôts etc c'est pas subtil ça
va rester un produit de niche pense
pendant encore un bon 5 1 je pense qu'on
peut voir dans certains marchés
spécialisés en trouver à voir l'intérêt
des consommateurs et des producteurs
je pense qu un très bel avenir on
pourrait tirer notre épingle du jeu dans
cette culture l'eau québec
[Musique]